Plea bargaining is right at the central.
In fact,
it's most of what happens in
the criminal justice system.
Prosecutors offer a plea either a
reduction in the charges most often,
uh,
which of course has an effect on what
the sentence will be in the death penalty
area.
It's particularly important because
most death penalty cases are solved is w
talked about before one or two stages.
Either the prosecution deciding to seek
the death penalty or quite often with a
plea bargain,
whether or not the prosecution
agrees to drop the death penalty,
that is withdraw the notice to seek
the death plenty in exchange for the
defendant pleading guilty and agreeing
to a sentence of life imprisonment
without the possibility of parole.
Today I want to talk about
plea bargaining in general,
uh,
in capital cases,
and a related subject,
which is the use of plea bargaining,
uh,
to gain the testimony of people,
maybe other people involved in the crime
or people charged with other crimes.
Uh,
the Supreme Court has said that,
uh,
we have a system of please,
not a system of trials.
A vast majority of criminal cases.
As I mentioned in an earlier talk,
our resolve with plea bargains a 94%
of all cases in the state courts,
which of course,
that's where the overwhelming
majority of cases are handled.
And 97% of all convictions in the
federal courts are the result of plea
bargains,
not trials.
Uh,
so trouser,
fairly rare plea bargains are very common.
Uh,
and that's how,
uh,
cases are resolved.
Uh,
when a person pleads guilty,
uh,
that's it.
That's a conviction.
Just like if the person had gone to
trial and been convicted by a jury,
uh,
so,
a person's understanding of what exactly
they're doing and what exactly they're
giving up when they enter a plea,
uh,
is critically important.
Uh,
nothing better illustrates
the power of the prosecutor,
uh,
in the plea bargaining process.
In the case of Paul Hayes,
a case that made its way
to the Supreme Court,
uh,
Paul Hayes was charged,
with forging a bad check,
uh,
for $88 and 30 cents,
not the crime of the century.
Uh,
but the possible punishment
under the statute and Kentucky,
uh,
for that crime he was
prosecuted in Kentucky,
uh,
was two to 10 years.
Uh,
the prosecutor made a
plea offer a five years.
Uh,
but that plea offer was accompanied by a
warning that if Paul Hayes rejected the
offer,
uh,
the prosecutor would file
habitual offender papers.
And if he did that,
Paul Hayes would be subject
to life imprisonment.
Well,
what happened is Hayes
rejects the plea offer,
uh,
goes to trial,
is convicted and sentenced
to life imprisonment.
Uh,
as a result of turning down the
plea offer and going to trial,
this is what's often
referred to as the trial tax.
Uh,
this is what a person
pays for going to trial.
In this case,
it was a license as opposed
to a sentence of five years.
Uh,
in death penalty cases,
it's a death penalty,
uh,
as opposed to a sentence of maybe life
imprisonment or life imprisonment without
parole.
Well,
this seems what happens in haze
here going from a $88 check to life
imprisonment,
it seems a extraordinarily
harsh as is this permissible?
The prosecutors had this,
uh,
ability.
Uh,
the Supreme Court said yes,
uh,
in the board and coach of versus Hayes,
which was Paul Hayes case on appeal
to the United States Supreme Court.
Uh,
the,
the court said the prosecutor can't
retaliate against the defendant for
exercising his right to trial.
Uh,
but this was part of the give and take.
The court set a plea bargaining.
It's Sorta hard to understand what
Paul Hayes had to give or take.
He basically had a choice between
five years and life imprisonment,
but he didn't have a whole lot of,
uh,
a bargaining power in that
process is very simple case,
a very small check.
Uh,
the prosecution was going to be able
to prove its case pretty easily.
Uh,
so,
uh,
the prosecutor gave fair warning.
Uh,
but then,
uh,
this is what happened.
Uh,
the court says,
well,
there can be some deference employee
offered some selectivity as long as the
plea is not sought on the basis of
some impermissible ground like race or
religion or some other,
uh,
totally improper and arbitrary
consideration like that.
Uh,
there were the sense in this case,
Justice Brennan,
uh,
or excuse me,
justice Blackmun,
uh,
joined by Justice Brennan
and Justice Marshall.
So this was vindictive prosecution that
basically the prosecutor was vindictive
and punished haze for not
taking the plea offer.
Uh,
they pointed to a couple of earlier cases.
the court had had decided a one
called North Carolina versus peers,
uh,
in which a fellow had been successful
in getting his case reversed on appeal.
When the case came back,
he got a harsher sentence.
The court said,
you can't punish someone for
exercising their right to appeal.
And they'd applied that same rationale
to prosecutors in a case called
Blackledge versus Perry,
in which they said,
again,
if a case is appealed and comes back,
the prosecution can't charge
a more serious crime or
more harsh crime to punish
the defendant for exercising
his right to appeal a justice.
Blackmun.
Uh,
excuse me,
just as Powell,
uh,
descend it here,
he said that prosecutor candidly admitted,
uh,
what he was doing.
And in his opinion,
the issue in the case,
uh,
is whether a prosecutor reasonably
might have charged Hayes as an abysmal
offender from the outset.
This is unusual in the way the prosecutor
threatened and then brought the
habitual offender charge against Hayes
or file the habitual offender papers.
Normally what happens is the prosecutor's
going to charge the most serious
charge at the start of the process.
That is he's going to charge
as an eventual offender
and then offered to plead
the case down.
And this is what we see
in death penalty cases.
The prosecution notices the death poem
puts the defendant on notice that this,
this case will be a capital case.
The prosecution is
seeking the death penalty,
but then at some point between
that notice and the trial,
it may be that the case will be
resolved with a plea bargain,
uh,
to a sentence less than less than death.
Uh,
the court has put some restriction on
some restrictions on the plea bargaining
process,
although it hasn't put any on prosecutors,
uh,
the person who's a pleading guilty,
has got to know,
uh,
the,
the charges against them.
Uh,
what the maximum punishment is that
they face if they are found guilty,
uh,
and all of the constitutional rights,
that they're giving up as a result.
And in case called Boykin versus Alabama,
the Supreme Court said a judge before
taking a plea has to take the person and
go through all of these
constitutional rights,
the right to counsel,
the right to a jury trial,
the right to confront witnesses that
is the right to cross examine the
prosecution's witnesses,
uh,
the right to compulsory process that
is the right to subpoena witnesses and
bring them into court to testify for,
uh,
the,
the defendant,
uh,
the privilege against self incrimination
and also the right to testify.
The defendant has a right either to
testify or not to testify and that's
personal to the defendant.
Uh,
and so they have to,
uh,
realize that a waiver of these rights,
must be,
uh,
on the record,
and the defendant should be,
although not always,
is told of the collateral
consequences such as deportation,
uh,
inability to get a license
for certain kinds of jobs,
uh,
in a that live in public housing.
A number of other things that may
be the result of a guilty plea.
That person may plead guilty
and walk out on a minor crime,
uh,
without going to jail or going to prison.
But there may be all sorts of
other consequences to that plea.
The person may not realize.
So in the ideal situation,
the person's going to be warned,
uh,
of all of these rights.
Uh,
also the plea must be a freely made.
It may not be a induced by threats,
promises,
misrepresentations,
uh,
or you know,
things like bribes.
Uh,
but it can be based,
uh,
on the prosecution's decision
to reduce the charges,
agree to a less severe sentence,
a withdraw the death penalty,
uh,
whatever it may be.
A cited in the materials as the
public broadcasting systems,
uh,
frontline documentary,
the plea,
which is an excellent documentary,
uh,
on the plea bargaining process and the
pressures that are brought to bear,
uh,
when a person can get out
of jail by pleading guilty,
uh,
or avoid the risk of the
death pony by pleading guilty,
uh,
or,
a much more severe punishment.
The trial tax that I
talked about a moment ago.
Um,
the supreme court has said that you
can plead guilty even if you claim that
you're innocent.
And in a case called North
Carolina versus Alfred,
the court said that,
uh,
that was acceptable.
Normally a defendant,
uh,
must,
waive the right to trial and all those
rights that I just described a moment
ago.
Uh,
and also,
uh,
admit their guilt.
Uh,
but the supreme court said
that an admission of guilt,
uh,
is not required,
as long as the defendant
knows what the choices are.
Uh,
he or she may decide to
enter a plea under Alfred,
uh,
because they find the pleased
in their best interest,
not because they're admitting their guilt.
Then there's also the plea
of Nolo contendere way in
which the person is saying
they don't contest the charges.
Um,
we've seen this a few times after people
have been sentenced to death and their
cases come back for a retrial carry.
Max Cook,
one of the people featured
in the documentary,
the plea has his death sentence reversed.
He comes back to trial to
retrial and the prosecution says,
Mr. Cook,
we'll let you go home today
if you enter a guilty plea.
Cook has maintained his innocence
throughout the whole process.
Uh,
but he's very nervous about risking
a another death pony trials.
So he enters an Alford plea.
He says,
I'm maintaining my innocence,
but I'm pleading guilty in
exchange for being released here.
He was once on death row,
once condemned to die.
Now he's being released and has lived
in the community for some period of time
now since,
uh,
since his release.
Uh,
the same thing for a man named James
Fisher who spent 26 and a half years,
uh,
in the custody of Oklahoma.
Uh,
having had two very bad lawyers at
two different capital trials and the
prosecution tells him,
uh,
you can have a third trial and risk going
back to death row or we will let you
go home today,
but you have to plead guilty.
Uh,
this gives the prosecution
some protection,
uh,
for,
the,
the previous prosecutions that
have resulted in convictions,
even though in these two cases,
particularly that people may very well
not have been guilty of the crime.
Um,
as we discussed when we were talking
about prosecutorial discretion,
a plea practices vary a
great deal among prosecutors.
Uh,
the state prosecutors are independent.
They're elected in most states,
not all,
but in most states and most
of the death police states,
the prosecutors elected
by judicial district.
So each one is independent of the other
and they can have different policies on
what pleased to make.
Starkest example would be in Houston,
which is executed more people than
any state except Texas itself.
Uh,
because of two very aggressive prosecutors
who over a long period of time sought
the death pony repeatedly.
Uh,
on the other hand,
Robert Morgenthau during the nine
years that New York had the death,
probably never sought the death Polly.
In fact,
he wrote an,
uh,
an op Ed in the New York Times saying
that the legislature shouldn't even adopt
the death poem.
So practices can differ a great deal,
uh,
from one prosecutor,
to another.
And what this results in of
course there's a geographical,
uh,
the depth point,
a geographical pattern in terms of
how the death penalty is imposed.
In 19,
uh,
95,
a study was done that looked at the death
pony from when it was first reinstated
in 1976 to 1995,
uh,
and found that more than half the death
sentences in the country were imposed by
2% of the counties in the country.
That is 66 counties imposed
over 2,500 death sentences.
And that was when there were a little
over 5,000 people sentenced to death,
uh,
in the country,
even in Texas,
which census more people to
death and executes more people.
Uh,
only 90 if the 254 counties in Texas
have sentenced people to death,
uh,
and in the country as a whole,
15 counties,
uh,
account for 30% of all
the people under death.
Since all this is reflecting the
different prosecutorial practices,
uh,
in seeking the death penalty.
And may also reflect to some extent the
demographics of the communities and the
willingness of juries to impose it.
But I would suggest that it's mostly
attributed over a prosecutor practices.
I mean,
one other example,
you can take Fairfax,
Virginia,
which has a population,
roughly 1 million people.
Uh,
during this time period,
a five death ponies were imposed there.
Uh,
on the other hand,
Hillsburg County,
Florida,
that's Tampa,
uh,
the same population,
roughly 37 death pony
cases imposed a 13 times,
uh,
as many death penalty cases as,
as imposed in,
in Fairfax County.
So we see places a great differences in
terms of whether it does some poster,
not most often it has to do
with plea bargaining very,
very closely related to plea bargaining.
Uh,
is the question of informants or the
prosecution making deals with people not
just for lesser sentences,
uh,
but,
for,
uh,
their testimony.
Uh,
there can be all kinds of bargains
fashioned a number of people that are
involved in a case,
uh,
and uh,
they,
uh,
one will testify against the other
perpetrators in exchange for sometimes
dismissal.
The charges,
sometimes for a reduced sentence.
Sometimes there's someone
in the jail who says,
I will testify that the
person accused in the crime.
Uh,
we'll,
uh,
we'll said admitted to me
that he committed that crime
if my charges are reduced
or if my charges are dismissed.
Uh,
sometimes the government offers rewards,
financial rewards,
uh,
and actually pays money to
people to be informants.
Uh,
and so the question came up first in a
case called on Lee versus United States
in 1952 and there,
uh,
the Supreme Court,
very close case,
a five to four decision,
uh,
where the court talked
about the use of informants,
accessories,
accomplices faults,
friends,
people who betrayed,
uh,
their,
their friends and what Justice Jackson
called the dirty business of prosecution.
And they said,
this raises real questions of credibility.
Uh,
but the court decided there
again by a very close vote.
Uh,
the court said,
we don't see any reason why
the prosecution shouldn't
be allowed to use this
information,
even though it was
obtained by these methods.
Uh,
Justice Frankfurter descended,
uh,
he said,
that criminal prosecution should
not be what he called a dirty game,
uh,
in which the dirty business of criminals
is matched by the dirty business of law
enforcement.
Uh,
his feeling was that the,
the contrast between the morality
professed by society and the immorality,
uh,
practice by a police and law
enforcement on its behalf,
uh,
creates contempt for the wall.
Well,
that was very controversial at that time.
Uh,
and at the time that case was decided,
uh,
but today,
no practice is more integrated,
uh,
into the criminal process.
Uh,
then people trading leniency,
money,
whatever it may be a for testimony.
Uh,
as one court said,
uh,
in the United States Court of Appeals,
the fifth circuit,
it's hard to imagine a greater
motivation for a person to lie,
uh,
then a reduced sentence,
and yet,
uh,
that happens all the time.
Uh,
in cases.
And some people get pretty good deals.
Uh,
in these cases.
One of the classics is Sammy the
Bull Gravano who was a part of the,
uh,
John Gotti mafia,
operation.
Uh,
he admitted to the murders of 19 people,
uh,
and yet he got a sentence of about
five years and was putting the witness
protection plan.
Uh,
he got that by testifying against 36
people who were involved in mafia crimes
and so forth.
Uh,
but it shows the tremendous power that
the prosecution has to encourage someone
to testify by being able to give a person
who committed this many murders you
would certainly think would be eligible
for the death penalty and certainly
would be put away for
the rest of their life.
In this case,
the person,
uh,
managed to get out after a fairly short
time and go into witness protection
plan.
Although,
uh,
Sandra bold later dropped out
of the witness protection plan.
Um,
what,
what the court was,
what was talking about,
uh,
in on Lee,
was,
uh,
the same question that we talked
about with future dangerousness.
Does the judge act as a
gateway or gatekeeper with
regard to whether or not this
testimony comes in or not,
uh,
or,
does the judge,
uh,
disclose this informer or require the
prosecution to disclose whatever the deal
is a and then let the
jury decide credibility.
Uh,
that's what the Supreme Court said.
you tell the jury this person was paid
money or this person is getting a deal on
their sentence as persons having their
charges dismissed and the jury takes that
into account in assessing the
credibility of that person.
Well,
this is an enormous power,
uh,
that no other person in
the legal system has.
If I encouraged,
if a defense lawyer encouraged some,
uh,
witness to testify and offered money
or offered any other benefit to that
person,
that that would be called bribery.
Uh,
and the person will be prosecuted for it.
but as we see,
the prosecution can
offer a number of things,
uh,
to require people to testify,
and to help.
The concern,
uh,
is wrongful convictions.
We know that in a number of the cases
in which innocent people were convicted,
uh,
they were convicted based on the
testimony of snitches or informants.
Uh,
even when the jury is
told what the deal is a,
even when all that information is put out,
uh,
it's still often impossible to know
whether this person's really telling the
truth or whether this person is saying
whatever he or she needs to say in order
to get their charges dismissed or reduced
or to get a more lenient sentence.
Um,
if the informant does not perform
as agreed to under the deal,
the prosecution can go after them.
Uh,
John Adamson,
uh,
cut a deal with prosecutors in Arizona
where they would not seek the death pony
for him if he would testify against the
other two people who were involved in
the murder of a radio
personality named and Don Bolles.
Uh,
he testified he did his part of the deal.
He testified,
uh,
the prosecution got convictions in those
two cases and got the death penalty,
uh,
in those two cases.
But the cases were reversed on appeal.
So the prosecution comes
back and says to Adam,
sinned for the retrial.
We need your testimony again.
And Adamson said,
wait a minute,
I,
I was only on board for one time
and I did what I was supposed to do.
Uh,
the prosecution appeal
that to the Arizona courts,
which said,
no,
you still have the responsibility.
Uh,
John Adamson,
uh,
to testify in the new trial right
after that Adamson changes is mine.
Writes a letter,
says,
I'm ready to testify,
but the prosecution decides,
uh,
that it will prosecute Adamson now
for violating the plea agreement.
Uh,
instead of the other two people that
had previously got sentenced to death,
it no longer prosecutes
those people at all.
Uh,
and,
uh,
results in a Adamson,
receiving the death.
Plenty Supreme Court says
no double jeopardy bar,
uh,
no reason that the prosecution,
even though he had pled guilty,
uh,
and he had been sentenced to
a fairly substantial sentence,
roughly 20 years.
Uh,
and it started serving that sentence,
uh,
that because he reneged,
at least they thought he reneged.
And majority of the Supreme Court and
this another five to four decision,
very close,
uh,
they thought he reneged on the
deal so you could withdraw.
Uh,
the,
the taking out of prison,
put him back where he started,
prosecute him.
And in fact,
uh,
the jury didn't impose that her,
the judge impose the death pony,
uh,
on Adamson as a result of that.
Um,
Justice Brennan a descended,
uh,
in that case saying there no,
it's not clear that there even
was a breach of the contract.
Uh,
and even though he did
breach the contract,
even if you assume that he did,
he immediately agreed
to go back and testify.
But at any rate,
that was a majority of a,
excuse me,
a minority,
uh,
four justices that,
that said that,
uh,
what do we see out of this
is this is the great power,
uh,
that prosecutors have a investigative
powers in terms of what to investigate,
uh,
which things to focus on.
Uh,
but once he's k what the charge
once the case has come in,
but then how cases are resolved.
Well over 90% of cases are going
to be resolved by plea bargains.
And often whether or not,
uh,
somebody plea bargains is going to be
based upon whether another person accused
in that crime or someone else agrees
to testify for the prosecution.
And of course,
very often cases are going
to go to trial as the bowls,
a murder case did with Adamson testifying
the first time and Adamson being the
defendant the second time,
all apart of the,
uh,
Arsenal that the prosecutor
has a in prosecuting cases.